hello everybody and welcome back to 2020
h3 experience we are now happening now
because it's 2020 and we have no time to
waste right here that's right
thank you to honey for sponsoring this
episode I have another bathroom story
the only bathroom I just saw we always
pee before the show
yeah and he's walking around you know I
just I guess I understand where they're
coming from but he had the key literally
on the metal front of a car bumper like
you know if they get the object so big
you attach the key to you so like it's
like a huge metal rod the guys walking
around with it car bumper I don't know
if they're making jokes like taking it
to the next level but because I saw one
with like a wooden spoon of cooking mmm
as a keychain to the key now you are
people understand what we've been
talking about yeah when you take the key
to the bathroom in a public in an office
setting they always put it on like this
stupidly big thing it's getting out of
hand
I guess it's so that you don't forget to
return yes Ethan like you ever done but
it's not that serious
almost once a week yeah well we did get
like a hundred copies they kept taking
them home in my bag on like 50 but I
think there's just it's getting a little
out of control it I literally saw an old
dude carrying a carboy with both ends
like this guys no shape oh we should do
Thea you know what would be funny for
the guests
okay we should attach it to the Gatsby
so they have to ride to the bathroom
I got us for the Teddy fresh office
little teddy bear keychains mm-hmm and
every time I go to the bathroom it's
like so fun no I love it got this little
teddy bear way made up for the teddy
bear keychains I was moved by that I was
moved I also want to give a quick shout
out to altered carbon which is this show
on Netflix that I've been desperately
looking for a show to watch for so long
thirsty drought-stricken dying of thirst
and then I saw everyone on reddit was
all hyped
altered carbon season - I was I didn't
watch sees one I just expect it with
some dumbass one of the there's so much
dumb Netflix shows was like am I gonna
click that [ __ ] I'm two episodes in this
thing is spectacular
it's like a um mm-hmm cyberpunk film
noir but the production level is insane
it's like it's just creative which is
fun to find all of sudden you can't know
where it's so good
ela fell asleep I wanted to keep
watching was it because I'm responsible
we got a show today well you do fall
asleep early regardless of if there's
only because we have a newborn baby well
I like a show is my point I didn't fall
asleep because of the show yeah I know
no I know
no I'm not trying to imply that at all I
would never imply such thing you know
okay I just remembered I have a story
that I didn't get to tell you from my
last exercise that if there was a video
it would have been hilarious
but obviously I'm not recording myself
exercising do you want to hear yes I'm
all ears
okay so I exercise with a trainer and
she put on one side this we have this
big medicine ball that's kind of soft
and if you throw it like against the
floor you have to use a lot of force it
doesn't really jump back up mm-hmm
so I do five of those like throwing
slamming it on the floor and then you
squat to pick it up and then run a
little bit to the other side and then
she put a second ball there for me to do
the same thing mm-hmm
and we only had a different ball that's
like the medicine ball they're using the
pool mmm and that one is heavy and it
bounces back I didn't think about that
and I slammed it super hard and then I
like lean to squat to pick it up and hit
me in the face mmm
embarrassing I see were you hurt and
this morning I was like doing this and I
was like ow what happened then I
realized oh yeah I slammed myself in the
face did Tyler laugh for you yeah oh she
laughing
through mm-hmm I think we've all done
something I've done that with like a
battery or something you know but it did
hurt a lot yeah I can smack in the face
with the might know is straight you know
but I'm sorry that happened to you well
you've learned a valuable I have I don't
think that will happen again I'm never
touching that ball again but okay
whatever you do to protect yourself
yeah thank you for sharing that you
you're welcome
now how do you write that story compared
to the post-office story that stories of
five it's a four story would have been a
ten yeah yeah yeah if you saw the video
of you yeah cuz I was so not expecting
it and it's landed like it's loaned me
at full force and what do you guys rate
that story everybody go ahead be honest
be honest I'm giving it a 6.5 okay go
ahead
Sakon yeah don't make me beg all right
give it a seven what it's funny if you
told that at a party why am I always on
a show like this that's not easy
can you not hear me you not here no we
hello hello oh something's going on cuz
we can all hear him you gave it a so you
can hear him he's in your the same room
as you I mean it's coming through
alright maybe I should have opened with
this story I know it's great but the
whole I like the whole rewind like ten
writing stories at the beginning of the
show yeah if you've got them but I do
what should I hold on to sixes no I
liked it I liked no I like this you
didn't good anyone else have any stories
they want it's great
Zacks telling me to test my microphone
can you hear me yes so is Zacks fault
yes okay so let's get right into the
juice here Wendy Wendy as main point
Wendy Williams
is denying fart gate now in the last
episode we covered Wendy Williams who
was caught ripping major ass her
television show here it is for everyone
who needs a refresher or miss the
originally live now you can't just slap
people on the booty yeah of course he
probably knows he's not a woman to a man
but you can I mean sexual assault
so y'all heard that and Zack actually
isolated it good Zack
that's why are you sure that's that
sound you're not messing with me no I
saw him extract my life obviously
ya know but I can't believe you got it
so clean Oh head again wow I really
that's gross listening a psycho once a
year fart say it's filling she's running
in my face but like how often do free
pass like that that genuinely once a
year yeah once a year hmm well anyway
she denied it she went through this
whole hubbub of denying it which just
made her look even more guilty she this
is amazing the hole that the links she
goes to deny it
by the way she calls it fart gate which
I really love and I thought she was
going to kind of embrace the fart gate
but then she goes to this elaborate
lengths to deny that she made a fart you
guys can judge for yourselves here to
release a fart I'm leaning over like
this because it's comfortable
no you're first of all the posture is
completely different she's leaning on
the Ottoman arm but if you look at the
fart standing on the chair she was
leaning she was like doubled over like
it's like here look she's like cramp
yeah body language girl I don't buy that
like oh yeah this is the same body image
no now she's gonna sit like this every
episode you enough
let me go back cause everyone's clapping
it's like a weird time it's like
watching their free lunch lady so guys
it's alright I like watching way
literally warm topics I like going
through this now for a moment and I
would like to have a private
conversation okay
she's getting a what I love the shots of
the audience being like she's she's
she's putting tea as like fart gate I
might have invented a lot because now
all other talk shows to do are trying to
do a lot really just me Wendy humble
[Music]
look at all of these what do you call I
know you would say dick Ryder for a
ma'am what would you what's the female
equivalent of a dick writer
those guys here nobody there you got a
riding herd dick [ __ ] I don't know
no idea mm-hmm Wendy writers I imagine
them like surfing on our vaginal pubes
like hanging on and flapping in the wind
anyone know why well they're small and
she's a giant how do you surf on pubes
though mass you know the factor
I don't lean over like this to release a
fart I'm leaning over like this because
it's comfortable you know if I sit like
this all the time you know it's heavy on
my spine I don't have the back up
yep girl yep yep yep who are these
people you know she ripped ass bro we
were all there we all saw it get the
back I like to release my hips yeah yes
[Applause]
belch or rub mites away I've been doing
this for 11 years okay on this show what
are you guys our fans back me up like
that you know what I'm saying I don't
see my fans at home when I get in the
[ __ ] and then they'd go for me they go
they don't give me that you go girl
treatment well do they you don't see
them so they might be I need okay well I
like to think that they are but
sometimes I just don't know I barely
fart you know why because gas gets
released several different ways and mine
is belching no you still fart
that's [ __ ] you the farts are the
[ __ ] in your [ __ ] decomposing that's
the process of by which will you absorb
your food through your colon you boat
you do both everybody does both you
can't say you don't fart Wendy why is
your name when do that
[Laughter]
anyway it went viral and finally like
she had a viral moment I would have made
a big deal like if I farted I would have
definitely been on that because farts
are always funny yeah girl huh yeah just
take a look at the clip and then I'm
going to go more in depth more in depth
I wasn't playing that look how she
doubled over first person Utley the
first thing that's key to notice cuz I
wondered maybe somebody faked it because
she was doubled over and she paused and
somebody had this genius idea to put a
fart sound in there because it would
look so real but they don't deny that
the sound is in there okay they go
through to an extreme lengths to explain
it away go ahead
[Applause]
okay I just want to make sure that you
all are on board with this clap if you
know about fart gate a girl like we
would have been laughing at that
second of all by the sound of that fart
I would have had to go change my costume
no that was a dry one I reckon I won't
even save the costume why we're throwing
it away it'd probably be soiled be on
soil tivity what I suspect cuz me and my
manager Bernie we went over it you know
prime like Bernie went over it with the
manager and so we said Wendy ice water
so stupid clearly you know there's
somebody who superimposed the sound it's
your show know what I'm saying and then
it goes viral and you know whatever so
that's what's up with fart gate although
Norman says he's got another theory
check the tapes the sound is there is
superimposed but mr. guy promised the
god wait was having stop Wendy's like
wait stop you weren't supposed to say
that
I would like to have a second person to
weigh in on this okay
my trusty Steve John Anderson Shawn
Shawn are you around yeah Jon know stuff
John just come back John's gonna explain
this whole part a whole buncha fine and
you know I know how to get down and
dirty right there was no fart continue
what do you know I want you to chime in
okay so during the show there was like
an incredible hissing noise I know you
didn't hear it but it was very
distracting to me so I'm liking the
controlling like guys there's a hissing
noise like what is that it's like it
sounds crazy but Kate the chemists with
Kate the chemist a okay John so we were
we were doing an experiment out here
with a tank it's called air gas and we
didn't have the proper hose wait
rip this tank for too long rolled up a
fish tank that's an age and we're guilty
personal this is yeah so in other words
when you drop like a piece of aluminum
foil inside the tank
ah it's supposed to float in midair okay
so it wasn't working okay cuz we didn't
have the proper hose India was just
coming no she had a meeting with the
whole crew oh yeah
and she was super serious and she was
like you guys find what happened mm-hmm
and then they all had to scramble and
bring out John you ripped that John
explained what happened he's like
Charlie what the conspiracy she's like
yeah we were doing the gas experiment
and he heard the hissing no dude he
ripped the ass lady she probably did
[ __ ] her pants he's like everybody in my
field has lost respect for me they know
you can't produce the sound of a fart
dude it sounds like there was a lab on
your [ __ ]
why no no that sound is just so stupid
that somebody off-camera is producing a
fart sound that strong then what do you
think is the producer yeah I mean I
guess they had this chemist on on the
same day is what they're trying to pass
it off on but it doesn't even it doesn't
sound like anything like that yeah like
what but just like skin flapping with
his story is that they were doing these
tests the whole time but just this one
moment where she's cramped over and
pauses then all the sudden just it's
just sitting but then all the sudden it
but also who does who does like loud
testing during a live show recording
there's [ __ ] isn't it I mean there
could have been something going on
backstage but yeah I mean that would
have required a the sound guy to have
left some microphone back there open
which you know is already unlikely you
know and be the microphone specifically
is miked on this one valve making a
squeaking noise like what loops it's
such a clean sound yeah that to come
through to Wendy I'm imagining if we
wanted to capture a sound like that you
would have to rewrite microphone just
like that right right right on it that's
such a clean beautiful fart sound you
could put that on like an audio library
you know and also the one her producer
kind of messed up her old story because
he says I heard the hissing and I told
him to fix it so what kind of set is
this where he says I hear hissing and it
continues and then makes a fart sound
well it's easily disprovable you can
just go back do we hear the hissing
creeper do No yeah Remo experiment I
want to hear
fart gate is not closed windy bar gate
is open and and more us more they need
to release the tapes conspiratorial they
never release the tapes I demand
witnesses let me tell you it wasn't
[Music]
normal
they say the average human being farts
between 14 and 26 times a day
I know Wendy hey what are you saying now
doesn't fart that much she's saying she
doesn't fart I can't believe you're
going to such great lengths I don't have
a guilty person God can you look at it
all right Kelly going on the interview
yeah
right it's on the pause how she pauses
right right right I'm fighting for my
life yeah you see everyone's lying just
like you'll see I was about to give you
some rhythm during commercials but you
just turned me all the way off in the
white shirt that's you I see three
Suzanne I don't know what team they play
would you play for my team three
strapping men on the front you're
[ __ ] freak it's just some confused
lady who's like farting rippin ass and
everyone's confused she looks like the
Cryptkeeper not far from our show well
at least I'm not like in front of a live
audience acting like I'm the [ __ ] with
the world as a podcast
nobody has expectations here Crypt
Keeper look at the Crypt Keeper and tell
me there's not a resemblance I swear to
god hold on what Wendy yeah
hold on I'm telling you there is here
look that aired edit edit edit edit edit
edit there I okay here once you see it
it's in the eyes and air y'all are
tripping if you don't see it okay smart
get over no it's just beginning
we demand answers the American public
demands to know looks like a frog don't
you think she looks like Kripke bear no
you guys are wrong sorry maybe a tiny
bit okay thank you that's enough we can
move on now uh that about I don't do
that that that baba baba baba all right
I'm ready
so anyway she denies it yadda yadda
yadda but then this brings me to another
Wendy Williams one she was actually got
a lot of [ __ ] recently because she
really is the worst and it would be sad
of me to not even mention that she got
cancelled before making fun of Joaquin
Phoenix's cleft lip which is a condition
as you guys know yeah you're born where
your lip is kind of pinned up towards
your nose and it's actually it's really
easy to fix they kind of just I don't
know what they do but you're just you're
with a scar here so he's got a scar from
being born with a cleft lip and this is
her take on cleft lip Joaquin was kind
of transform like when he shaves that
off but the way he looks at you
yes that's piercing I hate I was crazy
and he's got that good nose it dips way
down like he's happy with it so so am i
and when he shades off his my nose he's
got a hairline she is such a trash human
being like look at your face lady talk
about somehow other people look my god
you want everyone to look like he's
saying like how is he okay with his nose
yeah yes yes I guess she thinks everyone
should get plastic surgery have their
face by no Dan listen back she said he
says his nose he's okay with his nose so
I guess I am to the Golden Globe for
okay
well yes Beyonce sitting first of all
she smiled and I think that's enough you
know what I'm saying
imagine the show but imagine walk by I'm
fascinated by her
sitting down all night long
first of all second of all nobody in
this room is Beyonce okay you went back
way to for a different platform are you
know captivated by this commercial break
what dance this is the genius Tolman use
these buttons and I'm trying to use the
buns and nothing makes sense
okay stop I'm going the right direction
you see in the Johnny Cash movie yes and
he knows how to transform like when he
shaves that off but the way he looks at
you yes that's piercing I hate those
crazy period and he's got that good nose
it dips way down like he's happy with it
so so am I you see she thinks he should
get plastic surgery and look like the
Cryptkeeper
like her you know when you get a certain
amount of plastic surgery everyone
starts looking the same it's like a
different race so she thinks that
everyone should look like a frankly uh
it looks like she has a birth defect can
I say that looks like she came out wrong
I don't know and when he shaved off his
mustache she's got a hairline fracture
he's got one of those what he called it
cleft lip yeah cleft palate he's got
this yeah he's got this no I find it to
be I find it to be very attractive it
doesn't have that anyway to be funny but
so not you know I have to say after
watching a clip I don't think it's as
big of a deal as everyone said she's
just she's always elected I think they
are and complimenting him but in her way
well she's just a dummy she's just she's
just don't you know like dips way down
like he's happy with Blake or something
when he cites you cuz mustache she's got
a hairline fracture he's got um what do
you call the clutchless like the first
time I watching he's got this yeah he's
got this
oh so people just capped this and then
post which is funny but he doesn't have
that now he fixed that he was born with
that and he fixed it and he has just a
scar there so you know what do you get
anyway that's not really something that
she should make fun of cuz some people
can't fix it oh yeah yeah it's a real
shame when people can't fix it because
it's it's apparently really easy to
address yeah I had someone in school and
that had it and they they couldn't fix
it know how to talk to her about it so I
don't know maybe they just have the
money no no it's a real shame you know
um but I mean if it's like you can't you
can't fall her for this she's her whole
act is disgusting you know and I mean
it's like it's the whole shows the
problem so that's what that's my take
what do you guys think is she being
offensive here or is this just Wendy
passing gas as usual it's seems like not
that big a deal yeah it's not any worse
than calling her the Crypt Keeper Dan
you're canceled Zak good
I mean it's [ __ ] I mean why make fun
of that Zak you passed the purity test
yeah I mean I guess Joaquin's playing
the Joker but Wendy's the one that's
clowning I think you pass I think you
played it cool and you didn't give an
answer but I do want a direct answer
from you and so please no but I need to
know if he passed the purity test or not
you can't like a soundbite do it yeah
you got a soundbite for this exact yes
thank you
can you answer for me you know once you
request the soundbite you're all bets
are off dude thank you this is all the
soundbite I'm not actually
well let's start to a break we got a
crap ton of stuff to get to Frick load
of stuff to get to man it's only been 30
minutes we've only talked about one
story but I love talking about Wendy
she's one of my favorites she's my
favorite
that fart is pretty greats I think that
somebody's gonna be around for a long
time okay it's a work of art all right
sound bite that sound bite that sound
bite that I'm not touching this one all
right let's go to a quick break guys
we'll be right back with lots more HD
pod casts here to entertain you during
the actually don't come I was gonna say
during the week but it comes out on
Saturday isn't that a shame you know it
is what it is not such a big deal it
says okay listen listen so enjoy it on
the weekend yeah oh you don't have such
a great weekend guys go ahead and go to
break
by this time you've all heard about
honey the free online shopping tool that
automatically finds the best promo codes
available to you on the internet and
automatically applies them to your cart
you know how great it feels but did you
know how great it feels when you save
what they wrote jokes here so let me
lift off most of these jokes here saving
with honey feels like sliding into a
seat on the train just before the doors
closed honey if saving with honey feels
like a know wiper you know when you take
a dump and it's a perfect that's an
original joke I wrote that one right out
of my head right now saving with money
feels like when you take that perfect
turd and you don't have to wipe not even
once that is the best
then the one that they wrote is hitting
every green light on your commute that's
pretty good not that original of an
observational saving with honey feels
like finishing up your podcast episode
right as you walk into work save with
honey field this is one I wrote
finishing your load right before your
mom walks in and catches you you guys
know what I'm talking about right like
as a kid if you're in your room like
jerking it and then you finished and
then your mom walks in like a minute
afterwards you're like oh my god I could
have she could have walked in on me but
I just finished my load right back me up
Zach back me up Zach yes yes yes no but
in all seriousness we love honey because
it's not because of their jokes no but
because of their 30 because they save
you money for free
all you do is in two clips install the
honey extension on whatever browser you
use Chrome or otherwise when you're at
the cart of your favorite online store
it automatically searches the web and
applies the best coupon code to save you
a bunch of money take for example here
we were shopping at the gap for young
Theodore we love Baby Gap guess what oh
I'm just
oh I'm just stupid Ethan did it Oh Oh
what dude and it goes did it or did it
saved you $11.60 just like that and it's
free yeah
I don't even it's for it's free I
probably saved almost a thousand dollars
from buying [ __ ] online with honey and
it's there's no catch
yeah you know honey has found it over 18
million members over two billion dollars
in savings that's did you know that
honey supports over 30,000 stores online
including Macy's Target Sephora Best Buy
and more and they're adding more every
day
so using honey feels pretty great think
of it as a little daily victory plus
it's free to use and installs in just a
few seconds get honey for free at join
honey calm slash h3 that's join honey
calm / h3 now we only have one sponsor
today and we have to run to the bathroom
I'm gonna waste a little time how much
time we got Dan three minutes Oh about
three minutes let's add one more minute
so people always wonder today I've
explained this so many times but we
don't cut it's alive it's a live feed
even though we don't live with them it's
a live feed don't want to edit this is
the wrong don't rise to the rock yeah
exactly
even though we're not live we want it to
be unfiltered baby new Teddy fresh drop
comes out next birth or actually less
than a week now on Thursday this is just
some examples the 2020 Valentine's drop
really fun stuff I had to say I think
that this drop is gonna set the tone for
the whole year it's elevated the quality
is insane the designs are insane you
guys are gonna see and feel the
difference we are doing lots of
laboratory testing on our clothing to
ensure prove oh we are everyday ela
this is an original ela design we
workshop this hoodie or the sweater for
so long to get it perfect and it came
out amazing
you got the patches you got but there's
there's a ton of great [ __ ] you guys are
gonna want damn you are bursting with
teddy teddy bear bling on your necklaces
as well I designed this shirt I want to
take full credit for that although some
of that complicated I just really like
the the knit collar
yeah I think it's a great church so with
that being said I think we're about
ready to go back what do you think then
we're good all right thanks guys
[Music]
we're back we are back so my next topic
is a little bit delicate I'm not trying
to get canceled this early in the season
but I just want to discuss ok so Joe
Rogan when asked who he would vote for
in the Democratic primary he said Bernie
Sanders and he gave a really compelling
argument and I think a really flattering
argument for Bernie he said he's been
around he's so consistent he's been
saying the same thing his whole career
he's rock solid you know what I mean
and then Bernie said well here's the
video I think I'll show it for for
everyone's reference I think I think
I'll probably vote for Bernie him as a
human being when I was hanging out with
him yeah I believe in him I like him I
like him a lot what Bernie stands for is
a guy who look you could you could dig
up dirt on every single human being
that's ever existed if you catch them in
their worst moment and you magnify those
moments and you cut out everything else
and you only display those display those
worst moments that said you can't find
very many with Bernie he's been insanely
consistent his entire life he's
basically been saying the same thing but
for the same thing his whole life and
that in and of itself is a very powerful
structure to operate from so so Bernie
Sanders official Twitter app Oh
did this clip they just basically like
retweeted it right but they right yeah
and she quoted what Joe Rogan said I
think they actually made an ad of it
because it says paid for by Bernie 2020
Oh which is pretty amazing that they're
at it that they're that they see they
find him that credible that's so cool
for both of them but so now I guess
people within the progressive left are
outraged by this for example here's one
prominent tweet they says Joe Rogan has
had friendly interviews with Milo what's
how do you say his last name
Ian abolition innopolis I think and
Jordan Peterson yelled you're a [ __ ]
man on air about a trans woman vocally
argued against allowing trans kids
puberty blockers this year says [ __ ] and
believes the world is stacked against
men so enjoy okay so first of all even
if you're not happy with who Joe Rogan
is isn't it great if Bernie can pull
people from a different range of what
they believe in like yeah that's exactly
what you wouldn't need to be drunk right
or even just to find a common
understanding right right like but first
of all the claims she's making or so
outrageous first of all his interview
with Milo is what destroyed his career
but she said herself a friendly
interview what's the problem with that
you can't have a friendly interview well
apparently not a lot of people think no
you can't well so Milo Milo
he had this when he during that
interview he said something about how
like pedophilia is normal within the gay
community and Joe shredded him on that
so hard and pretty much got his whole
career ruined his whole career so to
just call it first of all your point is
valid enough but to call it a friendly
interview is not the case I watched
that interview and it was not friendly
it was very competitive so that's
dishonest
and there's nothing wrong with having a
friendly interview with me yeah
conversations are good these people
think that if you disagree with them you
can't have a conversation and that's
that's I mean I mean this tweet is just
so wrong everything about it then she
goes on to say Jordan Peterson again I
don't understand what Jordan Peterson
such a boogeyman and this progressive
left circle I don't get it I think he
has some side to him that maybe a lot of
people don't agree with but I don't
think he's like Voldemort it's like you
cannot be a solo we had him on the show
we didn't discuss any and his name and
your oath right I don't where I just
don't get that I mean I don't get it you
know you don't have to agree on
everything I don't think I agree with a
lot of business yeah I definitely don't
but he's you can't not say he's not a
smart guy and doesn't have things
listened to too unto listened to about
you know if there's someone you disagree
with where they're coming from
you're better off listening to them
understanding where they're coming from
and having that conversation they don't
want that conversation to even take
place yeah which to me just seems that
their whole plot their whole stance is
uh how will I that week if if both sides
will just never talk to each other was
this gonna look like a dance
she said yelled you're a [ __ ] man on
air about a trans woman so again there's
no context but context is that he's
talking about trans athletes competing
against women so obviously he's a
comedian so he's trying to be funny and
outrageous but I think the point he the
conversation he's having is a valid one
there's no context at all you know it's
just dishonest to frame it like oh he
just said you're a [ __ ] man like he's
just screaming that to trans people no
he's talking about a specific topic
which is contentious a controversial and
I do think that it's definitely a
conversation
say that a trance a man who transitions
to a women doesn't have an upper hand
against biological women and athletic
competition I mean that just seems
outrageous but at any rate maybe I'm
wrong I think it's a conversation and I
think it's a conversation because it's
this is all very new and some of it
might be unknown I don't know what
happened to your body if you're taken
yes certain so while I agree with you on
the cost value there's a conversation we
had but they don't want that
conversation they just date they just
write them off as you're a [ __ ] man
what you see what he's saying is you're
biologically born a man vocally argued
against allowing trans kids puberty
blockers this year again that is a very
contentious conversation to me that
seems like totally insane to give a
child something that can transcend wach
puberty I mean that's just they're just
a child I mean how could they how can
but any Matt the point is again I don't
know the facts I'm not gonna argue one
where the other but again that seems
like a fairly contentious issue so I
don't think that's outrageous for him to
argue that says [ __ ] yeah I don't know
about that
it's just thrown in there so I don't
know and believes the world is stacked
against men I don't think he believes
that either I don't think he even
believes that but again it's just thrown
in there so it's like these are like
their pre canned responses to do you
legitimize anything yes to say and you
know it's like they have this purity
test for the left if you disagree if you
get anything wrong you're not worthy
yeah
there's no gray it's like it's just it's
crazy I can't believe it's about your
weird direction that they want things to
move to but I wonder if um I do wonder
cuz this I mean this like has 14,000
likes I'm assuming this person wants
Trump out of office right oh yeah I'm
sure so how is this gonna help anything
they wouldn't just want to watch the
whole world burn it seems like they
don't you think you know what I mean
like
I made a tweet about it and then like
everybody's calling me transphobic
because I oh that's not that that's not
the tweet I made
that's hot girls for Bernie all I was
just giving contacts to Jose to the to
the tweet trying to give context by the
way what he said about Bernie is just
true has nothing to do with trans be
power of good character on Bernie side
and I yeah it has nothing to do with
anything why would you ruin that for
Bernie
they just hear the name Joe Rogan and
then they get triggered and go uh-oh
attack that ready he was already on the
show they're ready to not support Bernie
because he retweeted that that's it it's
not easy
so yeah I saw Anthony I know Joe Anthony
Fantana made a good response to the her
tweet he says whoever you're planning to
vote for would have gone on his show in
a heartbeat
mm-hmm but he didn't want him you know I
mean like apparently Warren was trying
to get on this show and Biden was trying
to get on this show
but he didn't want them on his show so I
said I said Joe Rogan interviewer
destroyed my load Jordan Peterson is not
the boogeyman your man too trans
Ashlee's competing against women
kübra blockers for children is literally
insane okay that's my tape maybe that's
my take I think it's a whatever would
you even pass your own purity test under
the same microscope nobody would show
each one of those are such a big
conversation you just can't but then
they here they go here's the top comment
lots of transphobia from here from you
here Ethan I'm disappointed I'm just
giving context of what he said how am I
being transphobic I don't even know how
to not be transphobic like how do I not
be transphobic see I don't know these
are all these are all new things like
how is everyone already supposed to know
what's the right answer to everything
but I do wonder your buddy blockers
there's a lot to even know about it
I mean on face value that sounds really
messed up to me too yeah on face value
maybe I'm wrong I know
some people already doing it so I don't
know there's probably a lot to be
educated about I have no idea but why I
already cancelled me for not knowing or
having an opinion well apparently I'm
transfer but I don't think I'm
transphobic at all personally
I personally thinking on that guy's kid
like but also I not I just said that I'm
just giving context here you know make
whatever judgment call you want about
Joe Rogan but I just think that this
person took everything he said totally
out of context and I responded Kay just
because I knew whatever I would say
wouldn't be enough for them and I just I
take the charge so outrageous to accuse
me being transphobic I mean I'm an ally
I don't hate trans people I don't hate
gay people know I support their rights
and what they're doing but it's like
they I'm not enough that's right this
stuff is so fresh I mean I'm definitely
your ally that's what's so weird is that
they want to cannibalize people like me
because I'm not I'm transphobic
apparently but they haven't real enemy
really transphobic people are out there
oh yeah
there's people out there that want to
kill transphobic people gay people and
all this chance people because of
religious beliefs or they're just I
don't know scared of it that's not me
I'm your ally you got it
you guys got to chill with this but I
also wonder if on Twitter these groups
they organize and they have a way of
amplifying their voice in a way that's
not at all representative vested
interests like forums
I haven't clicked through but I mean
have you taken a look at the person that
you replied to mm-hmm
have you looked at their profile mm-hmm
I mean I can almost guarantee you that
they're like a hardcore Biden or Warren
supporter you know I mean their what
their weaponizing this because this is a
useful tool to them to get an advantage
electorally
I I don't know who they support but I
haven't seen any that's an almost
guarantee you it's not Bernie
interesting well there has been a whole
play to discredit Bernie from yeah it
seems like an organized effort from
Hillary and warrant to kind of try to
destroy burning which I'm looking
through her profile right now she looks
like she's a pretty hardcore Warren
person yeah I figured there you go well
sorry lady warns boiling at 13% she's
gone
warned the whole thing is absurd too
because it's like you know you can take
issue with the individuals that support
Bernie but I mean you know if if you
claim to care about you know trans
rights and stuff there's nobody who has
a shot at actually winning right now
that is as good for those things as
burning so you're completely self
sabotage that is what I don't get yeah
without a question this is your goal
ultimately her goal should be the
Democratic nominee will win right
ultimately that would be the best thing
for trans people I think her goal if she
if you were if she was honest would be
just to I think they just addicted to
being a victim they like being in that
position because when you're the
underdog near the victim you can pretty
much get away with anything and I just I
don't know I mean I don't think they
really think that far they just think
about stupid it's unbelievable well this
if they amplify voices like this then
we'll never win another lecture yeah
it's like you got to get a broad set of
people on board right can you imagine
people like what like uh you know
farmers in Iowa what they would think of
a tweet like this yeah well thankfully
most of those people aren't on Twitter
and that's the thing is like the whole
Twitter thing is just it's it's a bubble
of media right bull but I'm just saying
the reflective of if you're Warren or
chiller Hillary Clinton it's so easy to
absorb this because you want to appease
these people and you think it's
important that there's a lot more people
than there are speaking of which how
much you want to bet that woman loves
Hillary Clinton and had no [ __ ]
problem with her going on Howard Stern a
couple weeks ago who is like a thousand
like has said a thousand times more
problematic things than Joe Rogan has
ever done are you kidding it's Howard
[ __ ] Stern like what so how it's
pretty I mean yeah he jokes around a lot
but he is I'm talking his story like yes
he's had a long career
stages of yard Howard gets a lot of [ __ ]
yeah well that's why she went on now and
not when she's running and everybody
responded great I thought that interview
was amazing until I saw what she said
about Bernie and now I'm back to hating
her despising her let's talk about that
because it's a good segue Bernie has
been slamming Biden on his history of
trying to cut Social Security and
recently Biden I just want to watch this
clip of him tripping I was goodbye from
[ __ ] Biden Hillary came out and she's
making a new documentary let's start
with this let's set the tone I'm just
chilling in Cedar Rapids can't wait to
watch a long documentary about so
terrible so in her documentary she says
he was in Congress for years he had one
senator support him nobody likes him
nobody wants to work with him he got
nothing done he was a career politician
it's it all just baloney and I feel so
bad for people that got sucked into it
you know it takes a lot of balls for
Hillary to call someone a career
politician and nobody likes him yeah I
mean look who's talking I like him a lot
she basically threw the most win like
she liked twisted destiny like in in
like 1 billion universes she wins that
election but she's the one version of
Hillary that's so unlikable that she
actually [ __ ] up basically a hundred
percent chance to win so if he gets
nominated will you endorse him they ask
I'm not going to go there yet we're
still in a very vigorous primary season
I will say however that it's not only
him it's the culture around him it's his
leadership team it's his prominent
supporters it is all mine Bernie bros
and the
Antonis attacks on lots of competitors
particularly women shut up she just
she's so big narrative that he's against
women where's it coming from
well they're they're grasping at straws
it's so insane cuz this is coming off
the heels of illa if he's supportive
women why does he run in an election
against one obviously he should have
resigned I mean that's literally when
you when you boil it all down that is
the mentality well I listened to an
interview on Howard and she was very
bitter about Bernie she was bitter that
he didn't endorse her sooner so she but
actually in part blames Bernie for her
loss and not herself with these Chillar
Lee Clinton videos Larry oh god what a
bitter [ __ ] I don't like her anymore
she had a good week where we all liked
her for one week so here is when Warren
by the way so so there's a story out
that Bernie told Warren that he doesn't
think a women a woman can win the
presidency which on the face value again
he's got a lifetime of of credibility to
back him up and that's not something he
would ever say I mean it's just stupid
to even think that so then the story
leaks right and then Warren all the
sudden it's like I have to confirm that
he did indeed say that oh such a big
story by the way this whole thing
backfired because Bernie is now almost
the forerunner and and Warren she's like
dead she's only pulling at 12 percent
nationally now at 28 and that was I
think the story ruined her that was so
awful she was already on her way out but
it definitely was the state through the
heart I think she was just trying to
take Bernie down on her way out but
anyway here they go listen CNN - which
by the way I mean everybody jokes on CNN
but this is just so outrageous watch how
they frame this
they're here you're saying that you
never told senator Warren that a woman
could not win the election that is
correct
senator Warren what did you think when
senators Andrew Sanders told you a woman
does not win the election
you dumb the audience even absurd how
can you not I mean it's just a fence
it's just why did you already decide
that he said it but that's not even the
good for the good follow up question is
did he say it yes because then let's see
who lets blood figure this out it's
phrased she already decided he did he's
lying now what was your but it's just
wow that woman should I don't to say
she's a professional journalist
interviewing potentially the next
president I mean this is outrageous this
whole debate thing like why is CNN
involved why are any of the cable
networks involved period like why do we
do it this way this is so crazy and
backward that these corporate news
networks run the debates like what I
actually don't know what well who would
do it that the Democratic just a
nonpartisan Commission something I mean
who pays for it though the the
candidates I mean that's pretty pays for
it now well I guess advertisers
partially pay for it as well but I
thought CNN would pay for it no I mean
they're all organized by the DNC and
they do it in partnership with these but
I think they must pay a lot of money for
the right to potentially say the
Kinsella goons advertisers yeah but it
just shouldn't be commodified that's one
thing like it shouldn't be a yeah well
we're profit bloomberg spent a hundred
fifty million dollars on ads which that
he outspent every candidate by like
hundred hundred times so he should be
able to do that either but there you
have it I disagreed Bernie is my friend
and I am NOT here to try to fight with
Bernie but look this question about
whether or not a woman can be president
has been raised in its time you know
they rehearsed this day this was like a
they set her up so [ __ ] you and then
here is the post debate conversation on
with a hot mic
[Applause]
yeah you did well yeah he's like our
mics are on dum-dum but CNN this is all
Orchestrator mantle now then CNN by the
way leaked the audio well yeah and she
she knows very well that this is being
recorded is gonna be a moment yeah and
he handled it actually like a pro
because he didn't let it turn into a
moment yeah and Tom's you tell her
pissed though yeah it's like because
it's such a little character he's so
smart cuz he could have gone he could be
like well you you did lie or you could
have tooken it anybody he didn't even
say anything negative about her he just
said let's not do this now I think he
handled it like a goddamn pro who's been
around watched Tom Styer he's such a
[ __ ] idiot
he's like he just wants to say hi to
Bernie it's like it now's not the time
bozo good good story he just has never
been more Larry David I love honestly
amazing you know top story it looks like
he just paid a hundred million dollars
for steyr is his name by the way Tom
Steyer like I mean who cares who the
[ __ ] is Tom's anyway I'm I'm team Bernie
yank is actually pulling at eight
percent which is exciting but I'm both
would be I mean I'm team Bernie and yang
speaking of Larry David there was this
great clip of Larry David telling Hamsi
to [ __ ] off here another great segue
[Music]
waited seven hours
where did the knowledge
[Music]
nobody wants to do this
why are you doing stop this [ __ ] nobody
watching this stop
just stop it okay
you understand no you done you done
I love dat he's still signed it
Thank You Larry Thank You Larry
[Music]
have a great night inside so mom
I waited seven hours for you who made
this he's right though those guys I'm
[ __ ] worst when I saw this pop-up my
heart stopped for a second cuz I thought
it was gonna be him like yelling at a
you know attendant at the parking lot or
something I thought was gonna be bad on
him and then I was so relieved it's not
laying into these paparazzi people hell
yeah so oh here's our here's our big
story the of the day you guys all know
Jay station you remember him we've
talked about him he brought back to life
Attica who was the youtuber who hadn't
he had taken his own life
and was very public very talked about
and J station that very next day
summoned his ghost via Ouija board were
Chalapathi people thought was tasteless
which is to put it mildly
he's also summoned Mac Miller lots of
lots I mean he's the trashiest person
not on YouTube but possibly alive today
he posted a video saying that his
girlfriend had died which is sad but
then when you look at the thumbnail this
is the thumbnail that's the thumbnail so
she apparently according to him died the
day before and then he went home made
this video and this thumbnail this
thumbnail is just unforgivable there's
no you know I saw this story and then
when I saw the thumbnail I was like you
know and obviously a lot of people are
saying that it's fake even if is so even
if she is actually dead which there's
about a 0% chance even if she is dead
this is almost even worse for him I mean
he looks like even I don't know what's
worse faking someone's death or doing
this if they actually died I think doing
this if they
he died is worse and I faking that
someone died it's pretty bad I think
what he's gonna do is be like oh my god
she's back
you know I yeah this is all he's gonna
resurrect her yeah he's gonna sort of
like necromantic I think she's his
channel becoming like super power I
don't understand to it yesterday they
went from like fake ghosts
yeah it's supernatural goddamn yeah well
we were watching some of his content
yesterday were just dying laughing and
yeah I mean he he's got all kinds of
crazy stuff he's doing like genetic
experiments he's doing talking to the
dead he's falling out I think what
happened is she probably went on him on
a short trip or vacation that though he
did uh she's dead and he's gonna rot but
people buy it anyway here's the video
it's four minutes and a half we could
interacting so yeah what's up guys
there's no way did he have another
girlfriend had died apparently yes so if
I'm the FBI and all the sudden these
guys girlfriends keep disappearing and
if this really happened I have this guy
in custody as an FBI so this has like a
legit a lot of views and like really the
vast majority are likes Wow
it's actually much better yesterday when
we were looking at it I think because
it's getting attention I'm probably just
like yeah it's getting dislike bombed
but uh when we came across it yesterday
it was it was all up those the top
communists try to connect with her with
a Ouija board for one last I love you
rest in peace
alexia we will miss you hero and pinned
and favorited
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
alexia what if she did that I should I
feel bad so in 24 hours yeah I was like
6 hours 6 hours prior was he wiping his
forehead yeah it's for his eyebrows are
tearing up from the tears come up what
if the wiping is over she's gone so if
she's dead actually you not know where
you drive it up so let me ask you if is
his girlfriend actually sorry for cry
yeah that's your year I thought he said
that they were filming together
subscribers go subscribe had about five
videos that we had filmed we were ready
to post on that channel while you're
just promoting her second channel go oh
you know I think he's explaining cuz it
because I saw someone said that he still
posted a video with all the same day we
were late he's just driving subs that
was our only dream to get 300,000 what a
[ __ ] scumbag that was her last wish
he's barely talking about her
after such a [ __ ]
wipe your eyebrows this guy would
[ __ ] murder his own grandma he forgot
him more subscribers videos who reports
into the song that's so amateur bro
because the the light keeps changing for
a while I hope you guys can understand
like she meant everything to me is she's
been living with me for the last four
months guys she's been my world for the
last four months anyway that long like
four months
yeah she's been my word for the last
four months I never met a girl like her
if she actually did die he murdered
earlier I'm sure of it not bad she's not
that though yeah he'll bring her back in
a week anyways follow me on Twitter in
there to whine fear so this is the video
he posted actually has credible like
dislike you mean a lot of likes yeah
yeah oh this this is the video that he
posted the same day yeah he didn't get
that many subs hahaha all that he wanted
to million by it's only at 323 because
he said that they were wait he already
posted another one seven hours ago he
said he they have five videos last
waster last one
and that's up button this is my account
I want to I want to see what the
comments are I love this this was her
dream from the grave I love you guys
thanks for all the support so they were
he said they were just under three
hundred thousand right or I wasn't
paying attention that was something like
that yeah cuz they're only a three
twenty three damn cuz she's annoying
look at this intro EULA coming who
wouldn't yeah so there's more to this
story there's ads on that video by the
way we forgot to mention I took
screenshots just because I couldn't
believe it but there's like hella ads on
that video
my girlfriend died rest in Paradise
spunk brought to you by Monday calm make
more time for actual work Monday calm I
love YouTube man they're the best [ __ ]
me right I'm a problem I'm a problem
[Music]
video of him going to the site where she
died also has ads on it Alexia's parents
they had set up a memorial on the side
of the road for Alexia so right now me
and ami are just honoring that location
we're gonna say our last goodbyes to
Alexia
not go such a bad actor yeah yeah
there's a funeral dumbass I I think I
want to watch the little thing maybe
they'll say it goes we just go see the
final goodbye I thought that's what this
is everything out to and we know Gus
unfortunately no Ouija board that's
coming up he's gonna melt this yeah the
parents said that up that looks like a
five-year-old did not yeah it looks like
you spent ten minutes doing it before
you shot this also those are fake those
are fake candles yeah yeah I just went
through part of the battery doesn't last
that long he clearly just set it up
those don't doesn't last that yeah he
just stopped at Party City for sure do
you guys ever Morial by the way there's
snow covering the ground in it that
teddy bear looks fresh as hell like it
looks like it just snowed the night
before picture
look at her sorry I gotta hit him we'll
have a real bed it's like this is like
as bad as YouTube gets its new bed this
is but this guy's willing to do anything
I thought he was at the level of like
Lance Stewart faking a ghost in the
house but this is so new it's a new low
to use that term that's overused a bit
but it is a new low but this guy is
quite literally willing to do anything
yeah Lance actually seems like a decent
guy that's what always happens you know
right there's like the there's
generations because when when all those
pranksters were going out of fashion and
new stuff we're coming up they started
to seem like not that bad you mean like
how Logan and Jake Paul looked in
comparison right they're different bad I
mean so Flo was such a [ __ ] and the
pranks in the hood work was probably
some of the worst yeah the worst that
was kind of like harmless oh yes well
kids watching that yeah we're some titty
grabbing and weird sexual stuff for sure
but this is the worst yeah this is
definitely the worst I've seen is that a
Givenchy huh it's like a designer $500
at I'll never find a girl like this I
get Jay he doesn't even have a real
tears draw don't worry we'll bring her
back to life in a way
without her and amazing so you know this
actually this guy kind of went above and
beyond what was necessary but I
appreciate the hustle this guy ordered
some ordinary gamer he said Jay station
is lying about his dead girlfriend I've
spent the entire night browsing and
checking with police departments in
Toronto and Ottawa no police reports no
local news agencies and worst of all no
family is confirming so I mean he said I
legitimately felt so bad after hearing
the death of this person I wish I didn't
try and look into it and lie to myself
instead I'm clinching my [ __ ] fist
and ripped some blood out realizing that
some [ __ ] actually lied about dying
like this I'm so [ __ ] mad well I mean
I
I mean relax it Amit Lee felt bad I mean
we all knew he was I appreciate you
going through the effort to apparently I
think we already know that I guarantee
you does anyone want to bet that he'll
bring does they want action on that that
he'll bring her back resurrector in a
week I mean is I don't want to hear
betting out of Weis I feel like we're
all I mean the other alternative theory
that may not result in her coming back
as they just broke up I had that thought
as well but she would show everyone
social media or something right or maybe
he just had an agreement like I'll pay
you if you don't say anything about it
but I think it's so epic if he broke up
with her that's posting videos they
pre-recorded so awesome she's alive yeah
chase station there you have it I wonder
has he posted anything let's see how are
people even taking this seriously like
making articles about it he obviously
made it our last day in Texas he
obviously made it up like what are we
debating he made it I mean Kobe a person
is but still being showed in classes so
wait that's a good point you guys
and it would be a little what's up well
so yeah just picked her up and what's up
guys I just got off the phone with
Alexia's parents they oh so this is les
upload well I'm certainly looking
forward to this is so a legendary yeah
Mike I was taught I was absolutely blown
away when I saw that well I was like if
she really died and before I really
looked into it didn't even watch the
video now I have no question about it
but I was like if she actually died I
wonder what can we say about it but then
when I saw that thumbnail I was like oh
I feel like YouTube needs an award
ceremony for worst and then like this
one could come to rest on YouTube that's
a great idea
no gun fall in the forest would be at
chop one guys
that's a lifetime achievement look at
this thumbnail people are actually
writing articles thank you yeah dude
just what the hell are we even talking
about oh my god
he's the trashiest dude alive just look
at him I mean just listen to him just
God can you imagine hanging out with
these people they might have kids
someday what do you think about that
they'll probably kill their kid they're
probably doing Mike child died video I
bet you he would they do have a kid they
ordered it off the dark web I saw that
video yesterday okay mm-hmm if they
actually had a kid if he had an infant
child three months old he would make a
video my baby died I can't wait for that
anyway there you have a chase station we
have some other exciting news you know
China has a lot of exports what did you
just link me down I just searched a
station baby oh he actually does have a
dark web beta you weren't
gremlin baby 2,100 bucks
so China has a lot of exports in fact
there they're beating the world with how
they're exporting everything everyone
gets everything from China but did you
know that China's number one export is
world ending pandemics it seems like
every pandemic starts in China probably
because there's so many people and poor
conditions for example you guys probably
heard about the core corrent coronavirus
which is the hot new world ending
pandemic but SARS started in China I
believe and the pig virus started in
China oh yeah they do it all
they're number one you know number one
in the world this new virus called the
corona virus is apparently infected it's
infected like 800 people - in America
but they caught them or here says 300 I
think it was gone up to 800 and it's
killed 25 that's China's official
reporting you know it's probably 10
times what they're saying I mean there's
a lot of incredible footage so let me
put this in context here
Wuhan were originated has been entirely
quarantined by China you cannot go in or
out of this entire city do you know many
people live in Wuhan guess I guess New
York for context or LA has like five
million or something yeah 11 million
people just in there and Mohan alone
which probably makes it one of the most
populous cities in entire world it's
just one of many mega cities in China
that's how pop my attitude is here's
what it looks like someone the entire
city is quarantined
no one in
no one out that's great it's never been
done before
quarantine in it and it's City this big
look at this no one in no one out taking
it seriously yeah but everyone in that
city is gonna [ __ ] die 11 million
people it is good they're doing that I
mean I agree look at this this was
pretty crazy too
someone taking a video of a doctor and
tears on the phone with a superior he's
all the doctors he seems to be a
translation I saw is that he's saying
they can't handle more patients it's
over capacity and he wants them to stop
sending patient's the people are trying
to send more doctors but he replies he
doesn't want more doctors there's
literally no room for patients yeah
there's what's going on inside one right
now and they're saying that they cannot
reach people higher up trying to read to
administrators but they can't reach them
this is a reminded me of Chernobyl yeah
that's right
it's totally true noble and China's
government would would do the same thing
if they say 25 people died is 2500 I'm
serious if they say there's 600 people
infected it's 60,000 but you see how
these were acting and you see how shady
it is someone's recording that like
because you know you'll get locked up
for life if you are caught going against
the old mighty Chinese government so
it's pretty scary actually in the United
States there was this first
from case of the new virus there was a
second this morning which city was it in
the second I think was in Chicago
because the first one was in Seattle I
believe yeah there was one in LA that
was suspected but I think they've
decided it wasn't actually that yeah but
yeah just as of this morning I saw a
sort of a second it started in a fish
market in Wuhan hmm because these virus
these pandemics start when a virus makes
a jump from another animal which is like
super rare occurrence but it happens it
makes a jump from an animal to human and
then our we have no resistance we have
no immunity it's a whole new thing it's
a mutation of the influenza of the flu
virus and that's what's so dangerous
about is that it's just this new thing
that could totally ravaged ravage us
patient zero who is not being named as
an isolation oh no sorry that's the guy
in America Washington get the [ __ ] out
of wahum I'm gonna wuhan my way out of
China the patient in Washington was ill
for four days after arriving the united
states and sought care based on the
patient's symptoms and travel history
doctors suspected the novel luhan corner
of our current cora and coronavirus
crack open a nice cool corona and since
specimens to the cdc so this guy was
cruising around Seattle for three days
yeah
the corona virus is in the same family
as the severe acute respiratory syndrome
SARS which killed more than 700 people
in 2002 and 2003 spicy
to date it has killed more than 300
people and has struck China Thailand
South Korea Japan and now the United
States the outbreak started in late
December at an animal market in Wuhan so
it was an animal market not a fish
market and 700 miles south of Beijing
yeah I think I read these corona viruses
come from cattle the virus can jump from
animals to people but now human a human
transmission has been confirmed
announced on Wednesday Chinese officials
are quarantine eing the entire city of
Wu Han it is emphasized how huge of a
deal it is we own as a mega city with
approximately 11 million residents more
than Los Angeles County the quarantine
of the scale is unprecedented is there
any more news about that does this from
Wednesday's it's just unknown still hmm
I heard this morning that the World
Health Organization is not declaring it
an international crisis yet yeah just a
Chinese death death man that quarantine
so crazy I think everyone in that city
is gonna get [ __ ] nuked by this virus
you know it's crazy though I did see
that in an effort to address all of us
they're like rapidly building more
hospitals right right and you know
construction in China is crazy and
they're saying you know they can build
an entire hospital in six days
what yeah I heard they finished one or
they're building their little they can
fit 800 people yep no week that's the
Chinese uh that's the Chinese spirit man
they just can't raw human power that is
though the flip side of it is they don't
care if people die building it you know
safety the thing is safety code all this
[ __ ] that takes a long time right here
there's no there's no delays there
just go to those fantastic what else we
got
what else I think I'm done I think I was
all the good stuff let's go over the red
at me mal boom how long we've been going
down uh let's see we started at 12:23
what no way Oh that was the break I'm
sorry I was thinking that seemed weird
yeah almost an hour hour and a half
let's go over memes and then I will
actually wanted to pitch your brother as
the bachelor but were two oh no we're
gonna wait we're gonna get moving you
got a hold of it yeah we put that in
touch with a good that's exciting the
bachelors they said no it works
so we've already talked about this I'm
just gonna be happy yeah well apparently
according to Zach we already got some
interesting applicants yes we did cutie
pies how am I gonna feel about that I
don't even know how so by that I got a
notice with you guys go ahead and this
is as good of a time as ever but when we
did the batch with Ian mmhmm yeah it the
conversation got fairly vulgar at times
okay is that gonna be uncomfortable I
mean for me well not for you but I mean
he'll was brother we're talking about
well that's between her and their
brother we're kind of vulgar are we
talking about yeah what I don't know
we're talking within there was a lot of
sexual talk yeah but wasn't stuff I'm
just saying I know a by the nature of
the contest it's gonna go there you're
probably gonna learn things about your
brother you didn't know right I already
learned through the show about him his
wiping habits so we're already well okay
but that actually changed my life
because I don't wipe anymore I try I
used to be baby wipes and now I'm just I
haven't transcended wiping that's what
he said then we were like you're crazy
yeah but no but now I found he won gone
in the end well you know okay
yeah that's why sometimes I do get an
itchy [ __ ] and I wonder well I'm
still white and it's there poop
after you squirt sometimes it it can be
lightly it depends if it was a messy one
or not because I I like the day I like
the day a lot yeah I go I go way out of
my way to make sure there's nothing but
the thing is that though it's so
interesting to see how you've grown
over the course you think that this is a
it's a long-term story art I don't use
baby wipes anymore though so your
bathroom struggles I mean it's been one
of the most consistent storylines on the
show we should maybe do like a and ovary
of then overview why because they were
so against the bidet
yes Troy I thought it was psycho yeah I
did and you are like completely it's out
anyway like amazing but I will say that
once a week my [ __ ] gets itchy
that's no good mm-hmm but I don't think
there's poop in it do something with the
know you're not using the soap right no
I'm not putting my ass and my poop in
there I don't think so I think it has
something to do with the fact that I was
always rubbing my [ __ ] with paper and
now it doesn't have its kind of
adjusting to not being always I do
because I think your [ __ ] in a sense
becomes kind of calloused from being
touched and wiped all the time not cows
but it becomes used to being like rubbed
and it loses sensitivity yeah I'm not
sure you get a calluses on your ass and
so it's adjusting to not being
manipulated so also much disagree well
I'll tell you what I'll go I'll do a
test yeah please do dude I did do test
before and there was no poop so that's
when I I was like okay I'm good to
disengage the wiping but I'll go I'll go
do further laboratory testing but to
answer your original question then I
think I am all for the show and I could
handle it and on the other side my
brighter is also
same he's all about the show oh yeah
it's gonna be very different from the
end it'll be great season I said which
is good yeah I wasn't even questioning
it necessarily I just want to make sure
yeah yeah right
[ __ ] you Dan right Zach thanks Dan right
yeah this one's for you Zach now you
gonna have to find one I don't know I've
yelled it down a lot on the show yeah
you yelled at me earlier yeah this
episode
dan are you [ __ ] with me where's the
pizza
where's let's review memes from the
reddit.com slash a traceroute
productions subreddit you can also
submit them via podcast to a tresor
productions.com along with any other
enquiries or questions you may have
first off president yeah yeah yeah
excuse me
it's just like a dead Kennedy shirt it's
not goth okay I didn't know go ahead
it's a punk band why is there two
Twitter handles look it's fake the
covering problem over it yes I take
issue with that mean how it feels
listening to podcasts of her I've seen
this a trillion times but it remains
live at and funny family members on
Christmas asking me about my personal
life and future he wasn't messing around
stay tuned the day of reckoning will
calm Papa said and then soon after David
BAM fiend Domino's Pizza CFO dead and
smart and former dojo pizza owner
sentenced to 65 years for sex crimes
reckoning
yeah that's what they said yes markleham
bro how'd you [ __ ] up about these
stories did he know them
well how is he doing during that time
were you
right it is a real story December 27 so
we should it just we should just ask him
on December 27 what were you done yeah
it's out of nowhere yeah how do you die
snorkeling though for real somebody just
stuck their thumb no tube that was it I
just lift your head up no snorkeling
means you're on the surface
oh I'm gonna assume you got hit by a
boat or something okay yeah there you go
just happened to be snorkeling Oh Donald
Trump retweeted Joey salads how good is
that I see he's changed his name to Joey
salad Dino he's gone official the
Democrats impeached Trump for crimes
committed by Joe it's retweeted Joey how
can any I mean guys this is crazy the
president retweeted Joe the sitting
president of the United States retweeted
Joey Saladin you know just I mean really
let that sink in folks I don't know and
like goddamn like a small word I guess
we know Donald Trump in a way two steps
from me
one step removed Asians are bad drivers
me and intellectual I would never say
that who's behind and what is it it's a
phone perspective so weird then his
knees know I'm sitting oh he's sitting
Gila becoming an American citizen to
escape conflict in Israel that's not
really what happened America starting
World War three that's what I mean it's
money though it's not like a refugee I
lived there too you know
man of my word if Trump gets a piece I
will donate my left testicle to medical
research you can quote me on this he
lied he raced this sweet really yeah
because it was he wasn't actually I
didn't believe it but I can't believe
this is a picture of Dan oh it was just
when you were in Idaho it was you
remember meeting yeah I think that was
the other Dan as a fellow Dan huh
okay look how happy you are both
together actually went into a shop and
he was like the son of the woman that
owned the shop he like came out from the
back and he's just like what the [ __ ]
mmm what kind of shop is it I don't know
I should say I guess it doesn't really
matter title it's a shop
it's a shop there's a little trick it
was a it was actually an Irish shop
Irish was like I don't know memorabilia
they sold like kilts and oh wow what's
the poet that's a hell of a business
well just cuz that'll identify him I
don't know what about his face well now
people know exactly where what state
he's in and what kind of shop poss
possibilities possibilities
possibilities why name an item at uh-huh
weird weird though
meanwhile the AC podcast is on break
this Idol I've upped a bit said I look
like him it's often been said when you
had a mustache
you think he's more handsome to me that
actor I love this photo like what how
who like this is so Ian I what do you
think I mean it's just a picture of Ian
Merry Christmas
well because this was highly up voted on
the subreddit Ian how do you feel about
people recognizing you on the subreddit
instagram my instagram i go god i mean
shut out lights or more I think in aa
lot of love
you should be more grateful to be here
very happy I appreciate that thank you
I know another Papa John's Pizza that
was not sliced this is a epidemic this
is a pandemic this come from Bhutan
Thank You Zach we're gonna order Papa
John's while Papa John is here I was
thinking I wanna do like a blind taste
test or raiding pot pizza slices cuz now
he has no elite well he still is the
majority stakeholder so he has a vested
interest in them succeeding mm-hmm but
it would be interesting to do a blind
taste test and he identify which is Papa
but that should be so easy I could maybe
not blindfold you and put some pizza in
your mouth should we order like ten of
the Papa John's to see if we get a nun
sliced one that would be really funny
idea yeah
should we ask fans to come up with ideas
of what we should do
yeah if you guys have ideas for the
pitch that we should do with pop I love
the air I have a few of my own but you
know things in the work yeah we don't
live in that lifetime no yeah we got him
yeah we got a capitalized I can't wait
or next episode on Tuesday pewdiepie
will be joining us that'll be really fun
and then via satellite via satellite
yeah of course and then and then uh Papa
is the following week or is he that week
Wow the following week that's right we
have next week on Friday we have Gus
okay
how nice so we do actually have two
gifts next would be three guests in a
row Wow Papa's on Tuesday or Friday
Tuesday Tuesday oh [ __ ] yeah scary three
in a row I get nervous when I have
biggest like uh Papa's got to be like
our most epic guest ever I mean just be
yeah I mean because of trying to think
about cuz that's the only way to really
not freak out let's pop me on this it's
like Jesus I'm just trying not to even
go there by maybe six I guess yeah geez
more interesting than Jesus everybody
already knows about
Jesus Papa hasn't told his story yet
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last why
is that big shift
why are you playing a clip that's pitch
hit down Zack it was a mistake well
don't let it happen again ever
and finally I'm just kidding I love you
time you know I'm kidding right yes I
was being overly critical for our
humorous effect it's okay it was really
funny yeah it's not shut up Dan you know
yeah dance is all burners I mean them
all the time but I do have that problem
where I like you do you you I credit my
be a dick because I think it's like
funny or something it just is actually
just yeah it's I don't know where I get
that from just a big bull your dad does
it a lot where he'll joke but no one has
any idea that he's joking cuz it just
comes off as real you know no I think
it's different I know you're joking when
you do it I don't actually get offended
but it's not funny it's just it comes
off it doesn't come off that good to
outside of surrani
even the inside observers it's like oh
he's calling me an [ __ ]
he doesn't mean it but still it's not
funny it's not that interesting so why
even say it does sound right yeah I know
I mean that here it's funny and finally
are not finally actually I guess people
are stopping students from doing
vacation cuz they I guess has to do a
vaping or they think it's gang signs so
these guys are stoked they were able to
get it into these giving this guy got it
upside down but that's fine I get it
Trump hey Siri how many missed this
isn't related but hey Siri how many
times did I how many miles did I run
today Syria okay sending missiles to
Iran today I just actually more than
what's written I love this he's side by
side is all
[Laughter]
[Music]
HTTP bingo Oh mobility marry this
episodes off the rails forgot to mention
sponsors ethan's guy at YouTube Oh
started dancing to is the freebie in the
middle that's Ethan's guy at YouTube God
I didn't know I talked about it that
much video won't play nobody made it
this far damn laughing from we need to
go to break and sensitive comment that's
not for interpretation very one play sub
sub sub that's a device already read
that one sub sub sub sub sub D D mega
due to infinity Bradbury it's not in the
document how this guy is like a mega man
this is crazy
how long have we been going for we did
that today right ela right ela so right
Ethan big boomer energy well that's up
again up for debate
right ela dead air what do you think in
are we gonna get claimed Ethan's fair
use crash course so let's see we
definitely did how long we been going
for Dan starts at 2 what do you think
Ian I think we did that yeah we need to
go to break forgot to mention sponsor we
see we did mention sponsor damn we
almost got it being hmm interesting
we've been going down this guy's so good
oh man this guy is actually doing the
Gatsby in public he went all black
though pretty classy we considered the
black yeah
but the red one out cherry baby you got
to keep a chair yeah shut up to this guy
bro I think I got to take the Gatsby to
Disney always got a service dog too you
know that's not a service dog I'll tell
you right now the sole service dog thing
is out of control
you just put a tag on it and these
people just a lie because according to
the law you can actually enforce it or
ask
right and so they have like unruly
literally like not even trained in the
slightest bit dogs walking around with
service dogs they just bought on Amazon
a little thing that says service dog
it's just it's so stupid people are just
why they're just liars why is the lawyer
you can't even ask it's some [ __ ] to
protect the two I guess maybe they just
don't want these actual people that need
the help getting hassled all the time I
don't know what's the logic and I think
that's fine but all these [ __ ] people
just lying about it just at least get
your dog trained what you want take a
close-up on this are they at Disney yeah
that looks like a Mickey Mouse
are they attending were there can you
see them merch yeah this guy stole my
idea there's definitely no what's this
what's this he's got some kind of thing
and he's got the horn on bro he's got a
horn you got the same horn ki Hong said
people with a [ __ ] air horn did he
actually bought the Gatsby that's so
crazy
you think he's a he's actually at Disney
you guys well that could be me but you
guys are playing can you imagine when
Theodore grows up and we do a family
trip to Disney and I bring the Gatsby
he'll be so embarrassed it'll be awesome
when you wash all the old podcasts and
find the moments when all the sound
bites came from there you have it that's
a wrap folks cool cool it's Friday my
dudes it's the weekend everybody have
fun to watch it oh it's Saturday it's
already the week
I recommend playing video games put on
the podcast mute the sound that's what I
like to do what you're playing right now
that'd be you got and be a moment Oh
what am i doing this weekend
you said play some video games that's
what I've been playing Diablo 3 on place
oh it's actually so fun but it's so easy
my guys like invincible I made a wizard
and yeah I'm on like um I don't know if
you're familiar with the end game where
they have the paragon or not the Paragon
yeah first of all I'm Paragon level 216
ok and the what's it called the endless
dungeon where you the Nephilim rift yeah
I'm on like 50 level 50 what you've what
you've gone further what's here right
yeah why aren't you impressed I had a
buddy that was like sort of a pro
there's not really like Pro but he was a
streamer that Diablo was like his main
thing and you know people like actually
compete with it they try and get as far
as possible right within a season or
whatever yeah he it was crazy he would
get up to like 130 140 something Wow
what class did he play he was a monk Oh
interesting because he would do with a
group and they all had like roles people
get really serious about it cuz they can
only play the game super casually cut it
so when I first played it when I came
out it was so tedious bro oh my god it
was terrible and now it's actually fun
to play yeah we play the same yeah we
started playing it because Ethan thought
I would like it so I started the game I
did like it but I just don't have really
the drive to sit and play a game right
now I don't know I feel like I shouldn't
do sometimes that's very fair but I
think it I've been lately just putting
on like how we listen to Howard and then
I gain I it's so nice she's relaxing one
down babies to sleep in hey do my emails
cool but it's just getting to the point
where it's like okay I'm just going
deeper and deeper
I feel like all my [ __ ] is like the best
it can be I'm creating for like 3
billion damage I was like what 3 billion
it's pretty awesome actually the bit
when you crit with a normal hit they
didn't even program it to display
billion so it says a thousand million
because it's like yeah it's like y2k
that's cool thank you
you have any recommendations because I
probably getting over table right now I
am still looking when it maybe someone
out there can help us still to this day
I think I enjoyed the most playing
raggle taggle yeah okay and I'm looking
for something like that we play peggle
Torey so don't see just that I know I
played peggle at some point I don't
really remember oh I think arcade
pinball kind of game [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's stupid what was there was
an old arcade game that was just like
this bust a move
because you move you shoot the ball and
it sticks peggle you release the ball
and it bounces ok you aim the ball you
shoot the ball I'll do a little research
yeah it is their music or not you want
to end the show well we're on our way
out we don't have to end it though what
do you want to eat because I haven't
eaten breakfast this is my one meal I'm
training one meal I finally used my
pellet on I got a pellet on a month ago
and I didn't use it once I used to
yesterday it was good this is the one
that had the whole controversy yeah
advertisement yes I bought it before
that all of you know so that I would
have bought it afterwards still abusing
you for my style wife seemed like I was
abusing I was fat shaming myself
whose class are you taking I wanted to
get the same honest Howard but gonna
find her Jen her name's Jen chairman Oh
Jen Sherman I think that is who I took
yeah really
but she's English no oh so I took a
different Jen yeah okay gents Sherman I
didn't okay I saw her why do you know
that just from listening yeah yeah part
of my ignorance is it anything isn't it
just an exercise bike
yes but it's got a tablet and you can
take live classes with instructors it's
like you're in a spin class okay okay
it's really cool where you kind of like
watch the class it's cool because you
got like the resistance and the speed
and you and you just follow along with
their instructions and they have all
this music they license it's like being
in a spin class at home and so don't
hate dan I know you're wanna hate him go
ahead and hey what do you got to say no
it sounds like it's doing some real good
for you
I didn't want dude you calling me fat
really then what are you trying to say
nothing I just doesn't it cost like five
grand or something no oh actually what's
the one with like 1,500 bucks which is
what normal frickin shitty ones I got
one for 500 there was like literally
garbage that's I literally threw it out
you buy the cheap ones then you stuck
with this huge piece of junk in your
house that you can't even get rid of
dodge it was 1,500 bucks I thought it
would be more to but it was really
affordable all right well that I mean
yeah 1,500 bucks the thing is one that
we borrow is like 600 I think and within
a few times do you use it already
started squeaky animals the worst yeah
and that's a huge thing that like how
are you even gonna throw it out it is
$40 a month that's how they do it so
cheaters and monthly if you want the
online classes and stuff you
I didn't know about that she's gonna
make you pull the plug now sorry what
yeah sorry me okay thank you what do you
want to eat you want Mexican okay what
else do you want
I don't know so let's just do Mexican I
really don't know you're the worst
I know I hate it either goes what do you
want
and then she it's always the same she
goes Italian well it's always the same
with you you go is one pizza or Mexico's
not their main options bro exactly I
don't she goes she goes you pick dinner
no I go Indian down no not true you
always say yes to Indian well I don't
want to eat Indy how can you eat Indian
food every day it's like Oh tastes like
perfume
you can't doesn't Indian food tastes
like perfume [ __ ] love Indian food
it's okay once in a while but give me a
break yeah it does bro and it's all the
same like it's such a great the most
variety of anything no it doesn't
they're like a bowl okay you bowl full
of butter and something with tomato oh
okay and then oh okay and butter and
chicken okay and there's more variety
want to chicopee's okay and with bull
and butter and chicken be definitely
more variety than Mexican I think it's I
love Mexican food no but it's similar to
Mexican food in that it's like the same
[ __ ] just a different configuration I
like it you know what's the most
innovative food Oh American yeah that's
it some bacon and sausage and a pile of
Pancakes wow that sounds [ __ ] actually
thank you I can't believe people
actually eat pancakes that's like a
daily breakfast fit
I like panic not eat that every morning
so dessert
it sits in the name pancake I say
alright Dan
all right so Mexican it is start the
music
let's go looking out here can someone an
event new kinds of food they're called
chefs yep they're fun they've been doing
the same bull [ __ ] like all metallian oh
I'm a Mexican chef
oh I'm French yeah suck dick I want that
new [ __ ] right - Mexican one of Mars
yeah he's in so douchey
you should want Mars food boy you on
it's working on
I want you medically modified pig bird
flew from Wuhan put a couple meat market
I want to go to the meat market whoo
hummus those guys are cooking up the
real news sharing like we need a
personal aid I think you need a personal
chef who's just like really dedicated to
serving you
your every need and thought my mom I
need my mom no your mom cooks the same
[ __ ] - that's true it's good there's the
next segment we have auditions for
personal chef looks so blank behind you
Dan we got to do something about that
well we got some plans the plans that
we're talking about songs almost over
okay guys I hope you're enjoying a
weekend I can't tell you how much I love
you and you wouldn't even believe me if
I said it and if you let dies tomorrow
I'll be sure - will you make it um know
about me yeah I'll put you as angel I'll
not be with Theodore be like oh don't
forget to wipe your eyebrows now
anyway I shouldn't joke with that you're
gonna live forever